blake snell on the hill today for the
padres second start yeah in his first
start dining against the diamondbacks
the one thing that stuck out was the
eight strikeouts in four and two thirds
and he's pitched last season 11 starts
takes them out for his first career
outing versus the giants austin slater
the top of the order at 282 average last
year and
swinging a mass and their strikeout
number one of the day for blake snell
did i just mention wipeout oh yeah how
about the wipeout sliders at slater one
out and here is mike ustremski
swinging a miss and ustremski strikes
out back-to-back case to start the day
for blake snow really tough holding off
that slider and once again in the dirt
that's exactly where he wants it here
solano did not play last night now the
one and two pitch to solano coming swing
and a miss blake snell is struck out the
side one two three to open up the
afternoon on the hill today for the
giants will be the right-hander kevin
gausman guzman 30 years of age he's a
seven year veteran at the big league
level here's will myers
two for five in the series
got him just elevate just a little bit
and in the end it is indeed the split
that gets him
starts off right about the belt and then
bottoms out below the knees
there's a splitter swung out and missed
he struck him out
that was just the beauty longoria four
is in rough three right-handed hitters
to face
blake snell
longoria lines this one down the left
field line and that's a fair ball and
he's got a double and that's the first
hit of the game so here now is wilmer
flores who's had three hits in five
previous at-bats lifetime against
blake's now
there's a broken bot bloop shallow
center here comes mateo and with his
speed into the slide makes the catch out
there in center nice running catch and
it's good to have that kind of speed on
the ball that does not hit all that far
two-thirds of the earth is covered by
water the other third covered by jorge
mateo here's rough riff at a home run on
monday
as ruff drives it into center field
mateo back at the wall he leaps it's off
his glove and out of here
oh
off the glove out of the yard i thought
he got some leather on it he did
two nothing giants and for darren ruff
the second game in a row that he's
gotten a start and hit a home run two
and two and the pitch to dubon is swung
on a miss tied him up with an elevated
fastball 95 miles an hour from snell
here's hosmer that's number one for
seven in the series the pitch to hosmer
fastball grounded towards shortstop far
to his right to get the ball and the
long throw to first by
dubone is in time to get hosmer wow what
a play
exceptional defense there by mauricio du
bonne first base runner for the padres
and now ha song kim will come up
[Applause]
center field hit deep
slater back pedals on the track he makes
the catch
two and two to gaussman that is on the
outside edge strike three called in the
fifth k of the day for blake snell one
out and a one out base runner here in
inning number three for the giants 2-2
pitch coming up here to ustramski
and a swing and a miss astremski strikes
out that's six strikeouts for snell two
down here in the third inning to solano
swinging a miss naked seven strikeouts
for snell one out for blake snow
lake snow on the way into left center
from basin
so the first hit of the day for the
padres belongs to their pitcher blake
snell the first of his major league
career somebody get that man that
baseball
as he
looks into the dugout let his teammates
know hey look i can i can swing this bat
a little bit too cronenworth flied out
to left center his first time
now a splitter is grounded right near
the bag at second do bone over to get it
runs it to the bag for one throws over
the first two a double play the inning
is over just like that two and two to
flores runner on first nobody out snell
delivers and that's a ground ball third
base man he's got it to second for one
chronoworth to first plenty of time to
get flores around the horn double play
certainly a big help there to blake
snail
trying to keep that pitch count low
being able to get two outs and once with
one swing with one pitch
mauricio dubon coming up and they're
going to intentionally walk him to load
the bases and go after the pitcher
gazman instead
swinging a miss and he strikes out
gauzeman the giants leave him loaded
off the line at first is flores solano
behind the bag at second
as myers bounces it to longoria on one
hop and longoria tosses it high to
flores who stays on the bag
one out
you know all of a sudden that one hopper
had a lot of personality by the way that
played first base when i was running
down bang bang
could have been out
all right let's take a look
at the flores had to kind of catch the
ball and then come back to avoid getting
hit by myers
the 2-2
chain
swing you're gonna miss he got him
donovan solano over two bounces this one
towards the hole kim knocks it down it's
short and can't pick it up that'll be an
error
i guarantee that larry rothschild
pitching coach for the padres just
grimaced because snell had a chance to
have a a real easy inning pitch count
wise
left side machado we'll go to second
base for the fourth shot that wraps up
the top of the fifth one out six in a
row retired by gaussman working here
into the fifth and turkson pro farm will
be next
to center fields that's gonna get in for
a base hit second hit of the day for the
padres comes with one out in the fifth
inning so two down first base open mateo
coming up with pro far staying at second
base
matteo
line to center field for a big hit
pro far coming around the throw from
center gonna be cut off padres are on
the board
jorge mateo driving in their first run
of the afternoon
there's the hanging breaking ball and
that one just kind of rolled up there
talking about speeding up a guy's bat
that's exactly what i mean
sends it right up the gut
profile scores easily
manio for two today
on the ground first and eats up belt
ends up in short right machado will end
up at first base
[Applause]
big hit into left center field for
hosmer shadow will round second but hang
around there
first and second with two down padres
making some noise here in the sixth
inning luis composano coming up here so
another 2-2 pitch coming up and it's
strike three call on the inside corner
and that is gonna end the inning so two
down and here is jorge mateo now the
one-two pitch
splitters struck him out swinging so
that's seven strong in the books for
gaussman and there's tyler rogers so the
bullpen inherits the one-run lead and
the base is empty for mr myers
myers to left field
slater going back at the wall
gone
tie game will myers rides it out of the
yard it's 2-2
a two-out solo home run in the eighth
inning to tie this game that's will
myers if you make him elevate
will myers will elevate the big kid
comes through big time so now first and
third the giants get a hit with a runner
in scoring position but he doesn't score
and here is solano
driven to right
myers has got it
dickerson's tagging here's the throw
home
not in time
and the giants take the lead two away in
the tent and marcano who collected his
first big league hit against this guy
peralta last night will try and keep it
moving for the padres as a pinch hitter
and the pitch fastball swung on a fly
ball to left waiting for a dickerson
he's under it and he's got it and the
ball game is over and the giants take
this series from the padres winning in
the finale in the rubber match in 10
innings
3-2